If you were put under cryogenic sleep
due to a deadly global disease,
what would you do?
You've just woken up
and an empty laboratory
with monsters lurking right outside.
No one is coming to save you.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do
and how to beat the Thorn monsters
in King of Thorn
, 90% of the world is going to die,
and the planet is just skipping along,
going about his day
when people suddenly see
a mysterious object
descending from the heavens.
It's not a bird, not a plane,
and it's not Superman,
but a woman crashing down and splattering
like an egg on the sidewalk.
But her death is not normal
as soon as she hit the ground.
Her body turned to stone, crumbling
upon impact, with her petrified corpse
just laying there for all.
To see her dying during
the holidays makes me think that she was
on the naughty list,
and her turning into some kind of stone
makes me suspect that she was infected
with some kind of crazy disease.
Now, if we talk about the worst
of the worst diseases out there
that can actually kill you within
24 hours of infection, this can range
from Ebola to the bubonic plague to dengue
fever and a miniature cockle disease,
which is a disease
that spreads saliva and nasal droplets
from infected people and can compromise
the lining of the brain and spinal cord.
But this chair completely turned into
some kind of stone thing,
which means that it likely
could be an autoimmune disease
that can affect
and showed problems on the skin,
such as the autoimmune condition
psoriasis.
This also makes me think that anything
that can cause symptoms to show
on the outside of your skin
is serious enough to make anyone freak out
because that stone
corpse means that shit's about to go down
and we have no idea what's going on.
But if you like the thought of pretending
you know what's going on
but really don't like our writer over
here, sorry,
then this is where Raycon will come in
handy
and will also be our sponsor
for today's video. Thank you.
Because just like mutated viruses,
they don't stop killing.
Oh no. These earbuds
won't stop killing the marketplace.
That's what I'm trying to say.
They're the new everyday earbuds
that offer an improved rubber
oil look and feel. They sound great.
They have a low profile in my ear
and their security.
I love it, thanks to their optimized gel
tips for that perfect in-ear fit.
I love them for my workouts
when I'm doing my laundry.
They even got me jamming to Stevie
Wonder on the daily,
so push the doom and gloom of the world's
worst enemy virus out of your ear
and make way for Raycon's offered eight
hours of playtime and 32 hour battery life
with a built in mic
that'll have your infected
screams and squeals sounding
HD at the press of a button.
That's so cool.
All the while
listening to the best of the best
at half the price of other premium
audio brands.
Still support the channel and click
the link of the description box below
or go to buyraycon.com/HTBA for up to 30%
off and a 45 day happiness guarantee.
What more do you need
brought to you By Raycon.
The public surrounds
this woman's corpse in shock.
As soon enough, the world comes to know
the petrifying news.
The World
Health Organization has just announced
that the corpse of this woman
was carrying a deadly virus.
The world is coming face to face
with a global
deadly virus known as acquired cellular
induration syndrome, or the Medusa virus,
which results in the body
producing an excess amount
of chemical compounds
produced in lethal quantities
that has a 100% mortality rate.
Turning people
within the second stage of infection
to stone within twelve hours,
and there's no cure.
But of course,
leave it to the Russians
like this guy who then tells the world
that they figured out a way
to beat the virus
by offering cryopreservation to people
whose bodies will then be frozen
until science can figure out a cure.
But the NSA doesn't trust his company
Venus Gate, the largest biotech company
in the world with infinite resources
run by doomsday cults, and they think
that they created this virus,
so they put up a top secret plan in place
to find out the truth.
A few years later,
the trial chamber becomes operational
and 160 members from around the world
gather to be the first of many
to be cryogenically frozen
as the destroyed world
waits for someone to find a cure
that will not come to most of them,
as they will almost all die
a horrible death soon.
And here we meet the twins Kasumi
and Shizuku, among others, as they drive
in busses to this creepy
Scottish castle inside at orientation.
The group is told that they will
soon be put to sleep
as their sleep pods and vitals
will be monitored by the most advanced
computer system in the world named Alice.
So even if the staff dies,
the whole lab will still be running.
But there's one problem
only one of the twins
can enter the trial chamber,
so they sadly bid goodbye to each other,
promising to meet up again
whenever Kasumi wakes up,
dropping off their belongings
and being injected with a tracker.
The 160 members head deep below,
blissfully unaware of what horrors
await them as they lay in their coffins
and pass into a deep slumber.
hehehe *awkward laughter*
Whoa.
Even if the world was in shambles,
I'd still be skeptical as hell
about all of this.
For one cryogenics. Are you kidding me?
You mean to tell me that I'll be frozen
with my liberties taken away from me
and I'll be looked
after by a bunch of kooks?
You are insane.
For starters, cryo biologist
Kenneth B story claims that.
Cryonics is impossible
and will never be possible,
as it proposes
overturning the laws of physics,
chemistry and molecular science,
which leads me to my next point.
If you told me that cryonics was invented,
then I certainly waited
at least a few decades
with ample research under its belt
and not a mere three or four years
before testing it out myself.
The problem with Cryopreserving
as of now is that when frozen significant
fractions of the water
within the body are converted to ice,
however, they are not truly frozen.
The chemistry is merely slowed down,
which can only be sustained
for a few months
if an individual was cooled
to temperatures
required for true long term stability.
Then, as of current technology, the person
frozen inside would not survive.
So I say we might have to let it
go on this idea.
Seemingly centuries later, Kasumi finally
wakes up, but something isn't right.
She puts on her glasses
and sees the most horrid sight.
Nothing.
No personnel, no lights, no one except
thorny vines encasing the entire room,
hugging the walls.
It's almost as
if she's been sleeping for decades,
but that's when all the Crile pods
begin opening up one by one and confused
members wake up to each other.
Baffled and worried.
Something is not right
and everyone knows it.
Kasumi tries to get down, but that's when
she comes face to face with a horrifying
mutated bat, scaring the life out of her
and causing her to fall.
And that's when the horror show begins.
one by one, these mutated devil bats
begin to descend from the skies
above as an army of bloodsucking vampires
begin killing everybody in the room.
In absolute terror, people begin
panicking and rushing to the door, hitting
and shoving each other
like their lives depend on it.
The door finally opens,
but there's no lift.
And in all the chaos and pushing
and shoving,
people begin falling to their deaths,
seemingly choosing
to avoid a more terrifying fate
by staying with the mutated bats.
But down the shaft,
the horror only continues
with this gigantic, terrifying
octopus eating all of those
who fall to their death
like a ten course cannibal meal.
But then this glasses guy
finally finds a second door
leading into another strange room,
and so the group makes a terrified dash
for the door,
sealing themselves
in to catch their breath.
However, they don't realize that
what awaits them outside of this
room is even more terrifying
that the monsters here themselves.
I knew nothing ever good came
from trusting a company
with the Word Corp in their name,
but I'm surprised Kasumi
even got out of there
without even a scratch.
There wasn't any good way out of this,
but we definitely could have used
everybody else to help me out.
During their kerfuffle,
I would have run near the elevator doors
and would have tried
to stay within the crowd,
using them as protection
to decrease the likelihood
of the mutant bats picking me off.
But I would have purposefully tried
to stuff myself
within the middle of the crowd toward
either the left or right side of the walls
surrounding them.
This way,
even if I got pushed to the front,
I would have been stopped
by the various structures
tethered to the wall,
and this part is very important.
So listen up.
If the power is not working properly,
I would be scared to take a lift
in a normal building
and these people want to take a left
inside.
This power drains a laboratory.
That's insane.
This is why being positioned
near the left or right
side of the walls
would have been the perfect spot.
The crowd would have helped me
from avoiding any bats
and on the off chance
there wasn't a left there.
Then at least I would have been able
to grab onto the side
of either of the walls
without being mindlessly
shoved into the empty lift shaft.
The group takes a breather
as we meet the other surviving members.
They try to figure out
how long they've been asleep for
and where those terrifying bats came from.
Just then, Kasumi recognizes
this guy's legs as it was the same legs
she saw earlier.
Let's call him Six Pack Stud
and she thinks something is not right
with him.
And what happened to the computer system
Alice,
who was supposed to be looking after them.
The group has more questions than answers,
but decide to get a move on exploring
what's beyond this room
as no one's coming to help them.
Just then they hear a strange
rumbling outside
sounding like the footsteps
of something huge they need to move now.
The group finally stumbles across a path
overridden with leaking water.
They have to find another route.
This old man has had enough
and he plops down and just sits there.
But then in the distance,
we see saliva dripping from the ceiling
dripping closer to the group
as the seconds
pass, menacingly approaching the old man
and he doesn't even know it.
Tall Guy gets annoyed
with old man's whining
and tells him to shut it,
but just then a flood of saliva spills
right in front of him as he looks up
to the most terrifying sight.
This dragon
saber tooth creature, the beast,
then chomped down onto the old man's face,
lifting him up with its alien mandibles
as the terrified old man
helplessly begs to be spared.
But this creature is no ally and clamps
down onto his neck,
decapitating his head from his body
and the rest of the gang reacts in horror.
They need to run, and they bolt,
skirting through the pipe ridden hallways
until this kid tells them to stop
running, claiming that this monster
is exactly like the one in his game.
This kid thinks he knows that monster's
weakness.
He tells the group that the monster.
Or attacked them because he heard them
and that it's actually blind.
The group thinks he's nuts,
but they are running out of time.
The monster is drawing closer cornering.
Their only exit,
forcing them to think fast
and jumping into the water below them
thanks to six packs, does creativity.
OK, OK.
If the first thing that you saw
was mutant bats,
then I think it's safe to assume
that there are probably more baddies
lurking around this facility,
especially if we've been asleep
long enough for plants to take over
the entire underground building.
Now, the kids said that
this monster had bad vision, meaning
that it relied mainly on echolocation.
But if that's true,
then that would still have meant
that that monster could see
at least a little.
A very common mistake is thinking
that bats are blind
when in reality,
they actually have very good vision.
It's just more sensitive than regular
humans, and some just can't see color.
However, if we used what the kids said,
then that means that this monster
mainly uses echolocation to find us,
which is done by emitting high
frequency sound pulses through the mouth
or nose and listening to the Echo.
And the only things in nature
that are made of flat,
smooth surfaces are bodies of water
and rocks.
However, anything made from materials
with small ridges or imperfections
like old metal pipes would likely bounce
the sound back to the bat,
giving them a specific location of where
this material was located.
Which is why
I think the group could have hid behind
the countless metal pipes
there and could have shielded themselves
from the monster's echolocation
as it would have bounced back on the pipes
instead of them.
And we were near
a body of water to jump in,
which is why I think
it could have been worth risking it
before simply jumping into the water,
not knowing the direction
of where this end or river would take us.
Kasumi tries but fails
to catch your breath in the water,
and she passes out
and the gang unknowingly leaves her behind
until they realize she's missing and Six
Pack Stud heads back in to save her,
barely making it in time to save her.
And he brings her back to shore.
But something is off
because tall guy here thinks
that there's more of those monsters
down in this hallway.
He's wrong.
However, since the terrifying monsters
are right above that dripping saliva
onto the cold steel floor,
the group looks up
and sees an army of those things
ready to pounce, causing them to run.
Six Pack Stud thinks fast and tripped
some of them
as the gang blast through the hallway
at mach speed running under this door
as they come to a dead end.
The gang now has no choice
but to fight these things.
Six Pack Stud gets ready to bring it on,
but not before a tall guy and glasses
guy decide to shoot their borrowed lead
into these beasts,
blasting all of them six ways to Sunday.
But the horror won't stop
as more of these monsters keep coming,
and one of them eyes Six Pack
Stud and tries coming for his face.
He demands that one of them
pass him a gun as he gets cornered,
but then suddenly Kasumi distracts them
by banging a wrench,
causing the monsters to come for her
throat.
She's about to die as the monsters
get ready to pounce, but then Six Pack
Stud gets awarded a shotgun
and takes this final monster
down, blowing him away
badder than Simon Pegg in an action flick.
But suddenly one of the monsters pops back
up, using its tail and knocking down
tall guy, forcing six packs to chase him
away before shooting the door shut.
This monster is not what it seems
as its corpse suddenly turns into stone.
This thing has the Medusa virus,
and now it seems as though it's evolved
to infects animals, too.
The group contemplates
how long they've truly been asleep
for as they try to take a breather,
and this nurse bandages up
tall guy telling him
that she was a medical professional.
Six Pack Stud
also loads up, while Kasumi and Glasses
Guy dig through the files
to find out what has happened
but can't find much.
Although something is not sitting right
with the six pack stuck
as he notices
something about glasses, guy.
Just then,
this blond haired girl finally snaps
thanks to the kid
not shutting up about his game.
Freaking out about him and the monsters
who are lurking just outside.
Tall Guy then snaps her out of it
as Six Pack Stud calls out glasses. Guy.
Firstly, our partners down here
are the only ones we can trust,
but that could be a problem,
since we don't know them well enough.
Heck. Six Pack Stud is a convict.
From the start,
I would have taken into account
how being down here
would affect everybody, and this includes
stress levels because this blond girl
just tried to beat the shit out of the kid
before she suddenly came to her senses.
This makes me think that she's losing it,
and if that's the case,
then how long before the rest of the group
goes crazy to stress?
Buildup can disrupt synapse regulation,
resulting in the loss of sociability
and the avoidance of interaction
with others.
Blonde hair chick going nuts already
makes me think
that the longer we stay down here,
the more messed up dangerous
and unreliable our group will start to be.
And I can't be leading
a bunch of crazies down here.
So believe it or not,
I'd break out of these golden hands
and start giving everyone
a free massage foot massage back rub
and even maybe a yoga session or two
to get every single person in this room
to chill as the better.
I help them manage their stress levels,
the safer off I'll be,
at least until we get to the surface.
Then it's every man for himself,
which is why it would be good
to make a few friends down here.
Six Pack Stud calls glasses guy out saying
before entering cryo sleep, they had to
take off all of their belongings,
but glasses guy is still wearing.
His chain necklace,
glasses, guy whips up bullshit and swears
he snuck his necklace through security,
but no one believes him.
That's when he grabs his gun and holds
Kasumi hostage,
finally letting the truth out.
He says that he planned to come here alone
until everyone followed him, claiming
that he was sent here to do God's holy
work, shooting the controls on his way out
as he drags Kasumi into the left, saying
that if anyone follows him, she's dead.
Before leaving,
he gives them directions out of this place
as the lift door closes on costumes,
terrified face in the lift glasses, guy
realizes that he's seen Kasumi
before almost getting scared himself
at the sight of her, but she doesn't know
what the hell he's talking about.
Back at the Security Center
Six Pack Stud prepares to go get Kasumi
as he owes her one
thanks to her saving his butt earlier.
The rest decide to join in, but just then,
blond girl suddenly finds out
the most horrifying news on the computer
they find today's date showing.
It's only been two days
since they went to sleep.
Not years, not months, but two days.
They quickly leave the center
to find more answers from Glass's guy,
who surely knows more than he's
letting on.
Back in the lift glasses, Guy tells
Kasumi of when he met her back
when the cryogenic chamber
started to open up,
he saw Kasumi Brute force
open the entrance to the Pod Bay following
behind her millions of live thorns
as if she was controlling them.
But Kasumi thinks it's her identical
twin sister.
She zuku, she's alive.
Kasumi begs the doc for more information
about her sister, but that's all he knows.
She left just as quickly as she came.
Just then, a massive rumbling is heard
as the lift trembles.
Something is going on outside.
Meanwhile, Six Pack Stud in the gang,
come across an atrium and bump
into more of those terrifying monsters
as the hallway
and the floors beneath are littered
with flesh eating demons,
so they head upwards
as quietly as they can.
Using the vines to painfully cling to the
ledge, the boy and blond girl go first.
Then tall guy follows.
But a second
major tremor blows through the atrium
as pieces of glass shards and debris
come crashing down, causing the blond girl
to inadvertently squeal for her
life, alerting the monsters below.
They need to get out of their Six Pack
Stud prepares for the inevitable
as he gets surrounded by monsters,
but takes one for the teen,
firing a round into the gas line,
causing the whole area to blow up. OK?
They could have avoided this hiccup
from the beginning
after experiencing
what the kid had to say.
We now know for a fact
that these monsters use echolocation.
They could have used this
to their advantage,
to a better prepared for what was to come.
They were already at the security center
and stocked up on ammo and weapons.
They could have foreseen
that they were probably going to run
into more of those monsters,
so they should have stocked up
not on just ammunition,
but robot items to distract the monsters.
The beauty about this
is that they could have used anything
is stuff that they could have thrown,
and as they needed to climb
the metal ledge,
they could have even used
their bullet round
to distract the monsters
simply by tossing one down to the bottom
floor of the atrium
right before they needed
to make their break by climbing upward.
The sound
emitting from the bottom of the atrium
caused by the thrown objects could have
likely led most of them down there.
It seems like 87% of you are not so great
to help us with the algorithm.
Subscribe now,
Kasumi wakes up with a start,
finding herself
still in the now broken left with glasses
guy seemingly nowhere to be found.
She gets up and enters
into a strange green room
filled with horrifying creatures
and monsters.
Suddenly,
she hears voices, and she quietly goes
to the sounds coming from the far-off room
at the end of the hallway.
Here, she overhears glasses guy confessing
to what he did to Six Pack Stud,
saying that he borrowed a dead
man's clothing
and snuck in
to pretend to be one of the patients.
He also claims that he's planning
to upload the entire database
of what went down here into a memory card,
just as a loud
rumbling is heard in the distance.
Six Pack Stud then goes to check it out.
Kasumi is shocked at this news.
Glass's guide then pops up behind Kasumi,
saying that he used to be the leader
of the R&D development team,
discovering this virus on corporate dime
and saving the world in the process,
which he hoped would have led to a Nobel
Prize as well as fame.
He says that it was
thanks to the shady boss
who lives up in the tower
that he unknowingly ended up
doing the devil's work and didn't
realize it before it was too late.
Just then, the memory card
finishes, uploading and glasses
guy gives it to Kasumi,
telling her to use this to show the world
the horrors
the Venus Corporation has done here.
But Kasumi isn't having any of it,
as she angrily blames Glass's guide
for the numerous deaths and the split
up of families that he cost just as behind
her, the most terrifying site lies
waiting for their conversation to end.
Another monster demon?
Suddenly, the demon lunges at Kasumi
and glasses guy pushes her out of the way,
telling her to guard
the memory card with her life, saying
whoever accesses the knowledge hidden
within Medusa wins the game
just as his head
is torn apart from his body,
resulting in a spewing bloody mess.
Kasumi lays there, petrified
just a Six Pack Stud comes in like a hero
to save her shooting multiple rounds
into the monster demon with a vengeance.
They then make a quick.
Getaway into the hallway, Kasumi
runs for her life and springs
across the gaping
chasm, barely making it onto the ledge
nearly falling but is saved
thanks to a Six Pack Stud.
But it's not over.
Six Pack Stud
then hangs her loose over the edge,
offering a trade wanting Kasumi
to hand over the memory card.
But Kasumi refuses.
Just then,
she notices the tattoo on his arm.
The same tattoo
as the man at the beginning.
This pisses off Six Pack Stud,
who decides to quit his negotiation
and pull her back in, but he doesn't know
that this mistake will cost him his life.
Mayday Mayday Squad to Dom headquarters.
We have a problem.
We officially know that Venus Corp
was behind everything,
and we finally achieved our mission
objective.
And now I've made best friends
with Kasumi,
which means that it only makes sense
that I kill her.
She's dead weight. Seriously. Hear me out.
Our main reason was to find out
if Venus Corp
was really behind the outbreak,
and now we have the proof,
but we're still in the middle of it
and there's still a demon
monster hunting us.
I would simply award Kasumi
with a certified haymaker
right to the face, knocking her out.
Sorry, and then I'd shoot her in the head.
Then, once dead,
I'd use her body as food as a distraction.
And this way,
if we run into the rest of the gang
on the way up,
we could have simply lied to them
about having killed Kasumi.
It is a fact that relying on helping
Kasumi
when we already achieved our mission
objective only slowed us down
and put our lives more at risk
than was necessary.
Six Pack Stud shoots
rounds into the oncoming monster demon,
but it's no use has this blood craving
creature just doesn't stop
forcing six packs to run before Kasu
helps them out,
barely escaping with their lives.
But this beast refuses to die, forcing six
packs to run to the end of the hallway,
making his last stand
and beating this beast with a baton,
crying out to Kasumi to climb
up to the ledge before it's too late.
But she isn't quick enough,
and Six Pack Stud isn't strong enough,
and the monster knocks him down right
next to her cornering them.
They are about to die right here right now
until suddenly a beautiful explosion
happens right in front of them,
lighting up the monster
as it squeals in pain.
Its tall guy and blond girl
who have come to save them
and they continuously light up the demon
with Molotov cocktails.
But Castle Meave
then realizes that the data chip is gone.
Their only hope of showing to the world.
What happened here is gone.
The group then reunites and escapes as the
ceiling then collapses onto the monster.
They then take refuge in a cellar
as Kasumi then outs six packs
start telling the gang
that he knows more than he's letting on.
Six Pack Stud
then reveals that he's a second lieutenant
in the British Special Forces, the SARS.
He's been undercover and took the post
of a convict for the Crime Sleep Chamber.
Once he found evidence that Venus Gate
cooked up Medusa as a bioweapon,
he had orders to blow the lid off of this
castle.
The gang acts in disgust as they try to
wrap their head around this terrible news.
six Packs then tells them that his plan
is to bring in the CEO of Venus Gate, this
Russian guy,
as he's been exposed to the Medusa virus
this whole time, but is asymptomatic,
which means he's got something in him
that they can use to stop this virus.
OK, I'd be a little concerned
with the rumblings that have been heard
throughout our adventure.
Has anyone else
been paying attention to this?
Because instead of
being below ground in the advanced labs,
we are now walking through an old ass
castle, which freaks me out a little bit
because I doubt that it's up to code
to withstand a collapse
from an earthquake.
Buildings in general
need to be able to redistribute
to forces that travel
through them during a seismic event,
whether that be in the form of installed
shared
walls, cross braces, diaphragms or moment
resistant frames to reinforce a building.
And I doubt that they thought
to install all of this
during the 15th century,
which means we need to be on
alert, as is not only the monsters
that could kill us,
but the very structure of this castle
could crush us if we aren't careful now.
On another note, we lost our only evidence
in the form of that memory card,
so that sucks.
So all we got left
is the CEO of this whole shitstorm.
And the CEO may be asymptomatic,
but that doesn't mean
that he's immune to the virus.
It could just mean that is, immune system
has only encountered a smaller viral load,
or it could mean that he's been exposed
to similar biological entities before.
I'm just saying there could be 1,000,000
reasons why this CEO hasn't
died yet from allegedly
being exposed to the Medusa virus.
Their best bet,
if they had to, would be to head
to the reception
area, break into the computer system
and find out
where the CEO's office is located.
Because the contents in his office
could more than likely revealed to us
some more information about the virus,
and that was the worst case scenario.
Just then, a rumbling is heard again
and the doors to the cellar bust open,
causing the gang to close it shut.
But this time something bumps at it.
Is it a monster demon?
Nope, just that old Russian CEO bastard as
he pushes, then all withered and beaten.
Russian guy then looks up at Kasumi's face
and gets a terrible fright.
He's seen her face before.
Or maybe it was her sister.
She's a cute
Russian guy comes clean, saying
that a test subjects went out of control,
and that was the cause of all of this.
His mission with this virus
was to take the power of dreams to forge
a new reality, but that's when everything
went horribly wrong.
Suddenly, floodwater comes.
Rushing in and fills the cellar quickly.
Russian guy
then points them towards a new way out,
causing six packs to blast a new way
through as the Russian guy leads the way .
He then spills even more beans
and tells them eight years ago,
a meteor came crashing down
upon a remote Siberian village,
causing everyone there
to die of a remote disease.
Except for this one girl, and it is here
when they met the most terrifying creature
fully formed from this girl's imagination,
as if it were through some kind of magic
thanks to this unknown virus
from outer space.
By purging the effects of this virus
and bringing this creature to life,
this little girl somehow survived Medusa,
and this led them to believe
that creatures formed by one's dreams
from the Medusa virus will never contract
the virus itself.
And this is what Venus Corp
was working on.
But this guy is a Russian psycho
and thinks that this virus is a blessing
in disguise, meaning humanity can evolve
through dreams into something much better.
This was the reason
everyone here was chosen as test subjects
to have their dreams experimented on.
Russian guy
says that after this little girl's death
and during the last two days,
he came across a new test subject
a little girl much like Kasumi.
But that's when everything went
horribly wrong.
Kasumi demands to know who this girl was,
but the doctor ignores her and says
how he couldn't
bring himself to stop the experiments
and that it's
now too late to fix anything.
Just then, a massive gunshot is heard.
As Six Pack Stud quickly
disarms Russian guy.
Kasumi has had enough and demands
Russian guy to take her to wear.
This secret girl is being held captive.
Suddenly, vines burst through the ground
in a storm of thorns,
and the gang makes a run for it,
leaving Russian guy to his fate.
But then suddenly another monster
demon appears right in front of them.
The little kid
then quickly runs under the monster's
legs, leaving this beast to charge
towards the rest of the gang
before six pack stood.
Then comes guns blazing,
telling them to go find the kid as he may
know the way out.
Holy crap,
we got another one of those demons. Great.
We got to think fast.
Good call on attempting to protect the kid
as he has proven himself
to be a tremendous asset
so far, and his gamer skills
have certainly prove their worth.
And you know, the only person
who hasn't done much to help blond girl,
which means she's got to go.
I would have pushed her directly
into the monster's way,
using her as a distraction,
as these beasts
tend to be a bit distracted
when chomping on human flesh.
If the gang thinks that they hunt
primarily with sounds,
and I would first aim
to destroy that part of their body
first over anything else
that would leave them
at least a little bit discombobulated
before escaping.
As without their superpowered
hearing aids,
they'll be a little more
than a helpless nuisance.
And this way we get to save some ammo
just in case.
Six Pack Stud beats the devil out of this
demon until his shotgun breaks.
Then the demon uses
this advantage and grabs
his face, ending his life
right here and now.
Just kidding,
tall guy comes back swinging Excalibur
and puts one right in his noggin saving
Six Pack Stud, but not before dying
from the Medusa virus himself.
The rest of the gang meets a dead end
until Six Pack Stud
joins them and tells them to quickly
dove in before the water gets them
swimming upward to prevent the current
from forcing them back down.
Ultimately reaching the ladder
and climbing out.
They don't realize it yet,
but almost all of them are about to die
as they get out.
The group finds a helicopter
as Six Pack Stud tries to get it to start.
Meanwhile, Kasumi finds a video recorder
showing footage of her sister, Shizuku
being infected with something horrible,
causing the medics
to take her into the castle itself.
Shizuku, who was inside the building
all along Kasumi, runs back
in towards the castle before Six Pack
Stud tries to stop her, but it's no use.
The castle then begins rumbling,
with the surrounding vines coming to life,
going nuts all around them.
This girl, she's caused us enough stress
and has single handedly ruined our mission
objective with the current destruction
of that memory card.
Yeah, remember that that's what happens
when we leave her with nice things.
She breaks them.
If she's OK,
who is in there, that that means
there must be some significant reason
for this,
as we clearly didn't
see her getting in the pods with us.
And since Kasumi
and she's OK, who are identical twins,
I say our best bet would be to kidnap
Kasumi and take her with us
and allow the world
to study her genetic material.
Now I know being twins
means
that one of them could have picked up
genetic mutations growing up, making both
of them to be 100% copies of each other.
Not necessarily a thing, but still,
I think it's a better idea
than letting her run away at this point.
She's our best bet in figuring out
what happened to the world
as the CEO of Venus Corp is dead
and we lost our only evidence
and that memory card,
which is actually kind of Kasumi
fault too.
So I say she owes us
16 pack stud, gets back into the chopper
and gets blond girl
and the kid out of there.
But at the last minute,
he tries to go back for Kasumi,
but blond girl sticks a gun at him
and threatens to blow his head off
if he doesn't take her
and the kid out of there ASAP.
The castle itself has morphed
into a terrifying vine dragon, roaring
with all of its might, and it attempts
to fly away with the castle itself.
Then, all of a sudden blond girl starts
coughing like there's no tomorrow
and accidentally shoots
the helicopter controls in the process.
Six Pack Stud tries his best
but is then violently ejected
from his seat, flying off as blond girl
and the kid go down with the helicopter.
Six Pack
Stud rolls off of the roof,
thinking fast as he falls
through the window and lance
right in front of Castle May herself,
who is just fine.
Find out where her sister is being kept,
Six Pack
Stud is distraught about blond haired girl
and the kid, but agrees to help
console me for his final mission
and one that will cost him his life.
Six Pack Stud and Kasumi heads
deep into the castle as they enter a cryo
sleep chamber.
But then Six Pack Stud
all of a sudden sees his sister show up,
but she's been dead for years.
Six Pack Stud knows that this is not real
and that this is actually Alice.
The castle's advanced computer
doing all of this.
She says her new mission
directive is to destroy anything
that affects its newly created host and
fights six packs in a brutal death match.
Alice
then reveals that petrified nation aside,
Medusa is a virus that affects the mind
and that those who contracted
fit a certain psychological build
with more than likely a traumatic past.
She says that Madusa makes those
who contracted highly fragile
with the new optimal host of this castle
becoming unstable if she lost
Kasumi, meaning dichotomy
is the key to stopping all of this.
We also cut back to two days ago
when Six Pack Stud met up with glasses guy
right before she zuku appears
before their very eyes as a plant monster
controlling Medusa herself,
and she spares glasses guy and Six
Pack Stud right before Kasumi woke up.
Six Pack Stud
then realizes that the only way
to stop Alice from this
hallucination is to get rid of the chip
in his neck and shoots himself
right in the neck,
ridding him of the microchip
and barely surviving in the process.
Phew.
My goodness, there are so many ways
that this could have gone wrong,
and really everything
should have gone wrong because one
the trajectory of the bullet determines
the anatomic injury.
But it's clear
as day that Six Pack Stud shot
that round right into his neck,
he didn't even try to angle it or nothing.
The Platzer is a broad
sheet of muscle fibers
that extend from the collarbone
to the angle of the jaw and serves
as an important,
superficial landmark, as patients
without violation of this layer
are less likely to have injury
to deeper structures within the neck.
The bullet also could have had
a more erratic trajectory,
which makes it all the more likely
that there's no way.
Six Pack Stud could have predicted
where the bullet was going to end up,
and even if he did,
you don't have to be a doctor to know
that a shot
to the neck would, at the very least
, require immediate medical attention.
Six Pack
Stud wakes up to realize that his sister
is actually a vain monster
and blows it to hell.
He then reaches for the deactivation code
to shut down Alice
and the whole operation,
but is stabbed through the chest
by a vine,
barely pressing the button in time.
And that's when it all begins.
The enormous plant monster
then gets affected as it struggles
to maintain its flight.
Elsewhere, Kasumi wakes up in a vine
filled room, with Shizuku
laying in the middle of the room.
Like Sleeping Beauty, Kasumi
then tries to go
save her, but in a horrible twist
sees her sister laying dead on the table.
But something is not right.
She then realizes that the woman on the
table is not Shizuku, but Kasumi herself,
meaning that she is actually she zuku.
It turns out that before they went into
the castle, Kasumi didn't want to leave.
She's a coup and in an effort
to stay together forever, tried to kill.
She's a coup along with her
but failed, resulting in Kasumi death.
Shizuku was so traumatized
that she blocked that part of her memory
and assumed the identity of her sister,
Kasumi, and that the lady in the recording
was she's a coup herself, evolving into
Madusa right after her sister's death.
This revelation causes the Medusa
hold on her to snap
as her own reality comes crashing down
right before her,
ultimately defeating Medusa
in the process.
Just then, Six Pack
Stud comes crashing into her
as they run for their lives
to escape the castle before it's too late.
Forcefully creating their own exit plan
before Shizuku's powers help them land
safely in the aftermath.
Six Pack Stud says to not give up hope
and to keep on living a soldier's
dying wish.
Just then she zuku runs into the kid
as they reunite and go in search for help,
hoping
to forget this terrifying place forever.
And if you ever want to leave
this terrifyingly sexy video pass,
forget to like comment, subscribe and
check out how to be playlist down below.